this week in our ey on money series we
are looking at costly mistakes people
make with their finances failing to have
a will is one of the biggest errors you
can make 58% of American adults have not
prepared estate planning documents
that's according to a 2017 survey by
caring.com we spoke to a Massachusetts
woman who could lose the home she has
lived in for most of her life because
her stepfather did not leave a
will I'm still in shock at the whole
process of what they're trying to do to
evict me and my family looking at these
first thing in the morning makes my day
Marcel Harrison is fighting to keep the
home she and her family have lived in
for nearly four decades and I said Do
you believe this that I just
received this envelope saying that I
wasn't an ear to my stepdad her mother
and stepfather purchased the then
abandoned property for
$223,000 in 1980 my stepdad did 90% of
the
renovation on his own he was very proud
cuz we had a place to call our own the
home now valued at over $1 million is
set to be inherited by a group of
estranged relatives in Barbados he
passed in
2011 he was very ill and I had to take
care of him
247 despite being raised by her
stepfather and acting as his caregiver
Harrison has no legal claim as his Heir
under Massachusetts intestate law
properties passed to the nearest blood
relative in cases where there is no will
well my options right now I will have to
purchase it from the HS that is what I
was told I have to do the house means so
much I don't know the word to describe
it but this is home to to me this is
home Harrison hired a lawyer to help her
Explore her options her neighbors also
created a GoFundMe page to help her
raise money CBS News business analyst
Jill linger writes about the importance
of having a will in her new book the
dumb things smart people do with their
money 13 ways to write your financial
wrongs Jill good morning and your heart
just bleeds for Marcel right and another
example of why it is so important to
have a will she has taken care of her
stepfather and yet now she's in the
situation what can she do well she's
done what she should do which is she's
hired a qualified estate attorney not
someone who closed your house not
somebody who takes care of your traffic
tickets someone who's very familiar with
the state law and how it pertains to her
situation I think unfortunately for her
this is something that has to be
negotiated she says we're trying to
negotiate with The Heirs and figure
something out but the problem here is
and it raises the hugest issue this has
already occurred that is why estate
planning mistakes are so difficult
because you can't go back and correct
them the person has already passed away
a lot of people think planning a will
happens when you're older in life but
you say anybody that owns property or
has children should do so immediately I
almost think that anybody with a
heartbeat should do it because estate
planning is not just the will which is
passes your possessions to your heirs
but estate planning takes into account
who is going to make Health Care
decisions for me who is going to make
financial decisions even if you just got
laid up for a while and I think the most
important thing here is that especially
when we have these Blended families step
families second marriages having these
documents in place is incredibly
important and you talk about four
essential documents that people should
have what are they so we start with the
will which is basically instructing the
the public what's going to happen with
your stuff but there is also a power of
attorney that is someone who makes a
business or financial decision on your
behalf a health care proxy who is going
to make healthare decisions on your
behalf and a general letter of
instruction this can be really really
helpful in just like how do you want
your your your funeral to go and how
should you talk about or arrange
paperwork with regards to your family
and and the estate going so I think this
is incredibly important because
sometimes people pass away they have all
these documents and you're the air and
you say where is everything so you've
got to communicate with the your heirs
and say this is where the will is here
are the contact people here's a list of
my bank and investment account
statements here are the passwords to my
accounts you know people are are dying
and they are leaving a sort of a mystery
where is everything here is the name and
the contact information of the attorney
of the accountant and here are marriage
licenses divorce decrees uh military
papers if you need a military cemetery
funeral these things are incredibly
important and I'm begging you please to
get it done I know it seems like you
don't want to do it it's hard but you
leave a mess in your wake if you don't
do these things now just look at
Marcel's case quickly what is an
intestate law um intestate means you die
without a will so every state when you
die without a will the state law
actually is the law that dictates what
happens next and that's what happened to
Marcel oh poor thing well keep us posted
on what happens next for her Joel thank
you